j'accueille rasmussen et jamel debbouze
tandja
bonsoir quoi
d'ailleurs au niveau où on était amusant
mais comme à la maison la voilà il ya
les meubles là où je les avais laissés
alors vous êtes ici tous les deux pour
angel a le nouveau film de luc besson
un film dont la sortie est entourée du
plus grand mystère
à commencer par l'actrice principale
alors on avait parlé de milla jovovich
en avait parlé de sara forestier
d'angelina jolie d'uma thurman et c'est
vous rie rasmussen qui apparaissait à
l'écran voilà un traducteur avancée en
trois mois
4 way a tancé pour toi c'est un mec ça
fait trois fois qu'il appelle ici
alors ouais c'est ça l'amérique où je
comprends pas assez cuit
ouais je t'invite à leur mariage
moi je m'en fous toi t'as melki cannelle
groupe i à la tournée à wil sg dans la
figuration d'indigènes ben voila je sais
pas comment les damiers genre de mec
tout attend en bas de mon hôtel à minuit
dieu mais c'est parti jusqu'au couple ça
suffit la possible il a appelé déjà
trois fois par an émission bien alors on
s'occupe de vous rieux car on dit rieux
oui rien
ces visites danoise effectivement est né
le 14 février 1978 à copenhague a mis
nombreuses neuf frères et soeurs est une
femme complète ce we see mannequin
d'abord un mètre 78 86 61 88
il a bien vérifié et en vous voyons dans
les coulisses d'un défilé yves saint
laurent collection automne hiver 2001
2002 tom ford le grand tom ford vous a
remarqué et a décidé que vous deviendrez
l'image de marque de gucci voilà ensuite
devait incarner absolue de rochas
engandzas de givenchy grande carrière de
mannequin actrice dans femme fatale de
brian de palma est aussi cinéaste je
vous ai fait une école de cinéma vous
allez réaliser des courts métrages dont
l'un a été sélectionné dans la
compétition officielle à cannes en 2004
voilà donc dû la femme complète
à quoi il manque selon m ça m'attriste
d'être sa matrice service 16,9 ramos la
donner des cours de français
on a fait ça en famille on a préféré
garder alors il y aura des surprises
tout au long de l'émission
mais à la fin un travail de fou parce
qu'il ya trois mois par les pas vraiment
un mot de français
manière chacun de 20 ans qu'elle est ici
pour dire pourtant elle dira toujours
fortement
comment elle est alors jamel comment
c'est incroyable
jing ça c'est pas de la ligue 1 tu m'as
sauvé la vie je lâche plus
mais qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment
formidable laissé savoir utiliser dans
les landes et zabel bon allez alors
comme en live à la gpe soir on s'est
fait dans sa vie mais comment me from an
j'ai pris un vrai qu'il mois à tourner
avec cette fille géré on se connaissait
pas voilà voilà
c'est pour ça tu te coupera gagne soit
on n'est pas en direct à qui peut couper
parce qu'ils assistent en direct
maintenant parce qu'elle est surprenant
elle parle des trucs comme ça sans
prévenir personne là d'un vrai culot tu
vois et elle veut des bancs d'école on
se connaissait pas forcément elle avait
l adn la fiche technique
moi je l'avais page là que je la
connaissais pas là nous connaissait plus
que je la connaissais et puis elle
n'était pas allée tellier impressionner
ni par lui que ni par nous on arrive à
15 a fort à chaque fois qu'on débarque
sur un plateau momo carif île chilienne
lan na waie au fait nous cake est viré
sont plus là sans françois paul et les
autres se fait elle n'était pas du tout
impressionnée s'est pas démonté elle a
travaillé son texte on a fait des
répétitions en face à s'éteindre équipe
qu'est ce que tu veux te disent le plus
il parlait pas français elle a fait un
film pour une en français avec luc
besson avec des bébés robben qui parle
pas ici de 9,5 français
ce qui traduit ici et qui parle très
vite aussi alors l'autre acteur du
nouveau film de luc besson c'est jamel
debbouze alors on dit toujours djamel
que vous n'avez pas fait de film depuis
astérix fragile les clefs de bagnole
quand même et oui les clefs de bagnole
bien sûr kefu un carton par l'upa
monumentale mais alors au départ besson
voulait bosser avec vous mais vous
voulez vous confié à gérard pirès soit
graphique mycrysis tullaye pas non plus
graphique et toi tu as dit non tu as dis
moi où cb sens où c'est rien ça blesse
on sait pas si la balance et besson est
plein j'aime beaucoup ce mec j'ai rien
contre bucarest micra physique bien sûr
mais mais j'avais envie de travailler
avec besson et comme je fais les choses
que par envie arêtes du hiatus nous
déconcentre ce qui me pousse les coûts
la vie oui donc descendu que vous lui
avez donné envie de refaire du cinéma
jamel
j'ai été très touchée comme il l'a dit
mais
moi j'avais envie de bosser avec lui
c'est son univers qui m'intéressent j'ai
lu dans les combats j'ai vu une équipe
assez j'aime bien son cinéma que j'avais
envie de travailler avec l'udc voilà
alors dans le film vous êtes un
mythomane qui s'est mis dans la merde à
force de mythomanie un type qui sait
même pas qui a trop menti à tout le
monde et à lui même et qui veut se
suicider et au moment où il veut se
suicider arrive alors une folle furieuse
une cinglée arrêt par le pitch est
l'histoire de quelqu'un qui s'aiment pas
en fait c'est ça mais qui va apprendre à
s'aimer
bah ouais c c c était facile à jouer ça
parce qu'on a tous un peu ça on nous
prend ouais si on a tous un moment donné
c'est tout se trouvait pourri bidon naze
alors là les périodes sont plus ou moins
longues et et en fonction des gens que
qui t'aime ou non tout en sort mais
quand il n'y a pas d'amour autour de toi
ça sortait dans la merde et ce en ce
sens faire de parallèle il eu ni de lien
avec ce qui se passe en banlieue c'est
la personne qui s'intéresse à ces gamins
donc forcément sont livrés à eux mêmes
ils réagissent comme ils ont envie de
réagir elle elle m'a regardé dans les
yeux elle m'a dit que j'étais très
intéressant que j'étais beau qu'elle
l'aimait et
surtout c'est apprendre à s'aimer pour
aimer les autres on peut tenir une
phrase très touchante dans le film c'est
quand vous dites
pour la première fois j'ai envie de dire
tout ce que je ressens ouais bon c'est
ça l'amour
si on ne sait pas si on a l'occasion de
le faire souvent ça vient véritablement
ce qu'on ressent je sais déjà réveille
toi oui à la chute a de la chance mais
même au plus de plus en plus cela est
vraiment c'est un vrai kif ça avait
l'air heureux sans quoi la là j'aime
bien ce qu'est ce qui se passe autour de
cette table
comment je me sens bien ma parole est ce
qui se passe à cette table ils sont des
vrais traîtres
c'est ce que j'aime bien la proximité la
féminitude alors le troisième personnage
du film c'est paris le paris des cartes
postales pour lexandre 3 à la tour
eiffel le sacré-coeur le pont-des-arts
très très bien filmé en noir et blanc
c'est sur ce qui est génial c'est comme
toi je regarde si j'ai pas eu de
détecteur de kamel alors j'ai reçu un
texto de mon neveu qui me dit voici ma
pleuré en voyant l'extrait du film il
m'a dit qu'il aimait pas qu'en pompant
était triste et il a trois piges wassim
c'est du cinéma
viva faute aurait il a la patate
elles sont estimées en attendant son
histoire cliff skiff mais moi j'ai de la
chance d'avoir des gens qui m'aiment je
te voir en vrai c'est illégal trésor
tout tu peux monter descendre faire des
millions d'entrées être le meilleur
joueur de foot du monde avec le plus
grande allée des philosophes et la plus
belle des femmes
si ta personne qui fait quitter mais qui
te le dit qu'ils étaient moins merde
t'es une merde voilà donc pour tourner
un pari sans voiture sans bateau il
fallait tourner deux bonnes heures le
week-end ou battrions matin ouais à 4h
du mat et voir comment tu faisais je
dormais pas c'était pendant l'été mais
c'est un vrai qu'il de tourner à paris
moi j'adore paris l'équipe ce qui
aperçoit l et les loups-garous de son
huit mois je
chez la plus belle ville du monde tu la
prends plein de 4 l'été parce que
véritablement tu la vois là tu vois les
pavés tu voi et les monuments qui
surtout ce qu'il a montré pour descendre
trois le pont de bir hakeim ça c'est
déjà choisi vraiment les havrais on
n'est pas magique
ouais on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
enfin bat vous avez regardé votre caméra
dit oui ça tu n'as jamais fait rire oh
là là tous les deux en même temps vous
regarder la caméra où il ya la lumière
rouge et vous dites
magnéto serge là quand on dit qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on n'a pas
magnéto serge l'a23 magnéto ch